i bill nighy my name is marcelina this
is my son Ohio and we have a question
about your perspective on ghosts and
also what do you think happens to your
life energy that ceases after you die is
it just Pushing Daisies Thank You Marcia
greetings this is people have wondered
about life after death since there have
been people it goes way way back when we
start with ghosts I'll tell you I don't
think there is any such thing I don't
think there's anything to be afraid of
when it comes to ghosts you know I'm a
member of both the skeptics and the
Council for scientific inquiry and we
have looked and looked for haunted
houses for ghosts and cemeteries for
psychics who believe they're in touch
with people who are dead and there is
absolutely no credible evidence there's
no reason to believe that they're ghosts
or life after death people have tried
and tried and you may know that Houdini
the famous magician said if anybody can
come back from the dead it's me man I'm
coming and he never got in touch with
anyone no one ever heard from him he had
a secret word between he and his mother
that he said you know I'll give you the
secret word when I come back and you
know what the secret word is nobody
knows it was secret and he never came
back but what happens to humans we our
brains are so active we imagine so many
things and we're always looking for
cause and effect that is to say when you
hear a bump in the night you want to
know what caused it you want to know
what brought it on and the first thing
you might imagine is that there's some
body or some entity out there causing
this effect the bump but you can't see
it so then we intuitively are
instinctively for ancient reasons
put a pattern on it we imagine it has an
agent as we call it but there's
something out there some agent is
causing this but it could be the wind
blew and knocked the candle over and
there's no ghosts and just to get over
it don't be afraid of that now when it
comes to life after death I've thought
about this quite a bit and what happens
what do you like when you're dead if you
watch people age like my grandmother my
beloved grandmother she was so smart
when I was a little kid she collected
wildflowers she was very skilled at as
an artist she could draw landscapes and
she was like a naturalist traditionally
she would draw detailed pictures of
flowers depicting they're very detailed
parts petal stamen pistols and so on but
as she got older she got dementia she
could not remember things she didn't
recognize me and so she eventually died
of old age and I just don't see any
evidence that she would suddenly be a
young person as an after dead ghost
entity it looks like to me this life is
all you get this is it there's nothing
afterwards so what you got to do is live
this life as best you can
that's the way to go and if it does turn
out there's an afterlife and we all turn
young again and can play rugby or
whatever it is we want to do so much the
better but I see no evidence for it and
for your son there there are no ghosts
sorry
and your friends who believe in ghosts
you can outwit them you will be ahead of
them because you will not waste energy
running around looking for ghosts
instead you'll close the window to keep
the candle from blowing over whatever
made your friend believe in a ghost
carry on I'm sorry but it seems to be
apparently this is all you get
[Music]